Best known for playing Tommy Oliver
in the "Power Rangers" franchise,
actor and mixed martial artist Jason David
Frank died at the age of 49 on November 19.
As of the making of this video, the cause
of his death has not been made public.
Even though "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers"
only aired for three seasons back in the '90s,
Frank stayed connected to the "Power
Rangers" franchise. While some might
write the series off as a silly show for
kids, many episodes explored important
themes like friendship and responsibility. The
simplistic character designs were an easy way
to capture a child's imagination while
delivering some valuable life lessons.
Frank played Tommy Oliver, AKA the Green
Ranger, as recently as 2018, and he continued to
demonstrate his pride in the franchise on social
media. The character was initially introduced
as a short-term antagonist, but Frank's dynamic
performance and extensive martial arts training
helped him carve out a permanent place for the
character. If you're a fan of Frank's work, then
you'll be glad to know that his final project pays
homage to the years he spent as the Green Ranger.
From the looks of it, "Legend of the White
Dragon" is a blend of fantasy, science fiction,
and dystopian action-thriller. The crowdfunded
film began as a Kickstarter campaign in March
2020, reaching its $500,000 goal only a
few months later. In July 2021, Frank told
ComicBook.com that a private investor took over
from there, but the film's future is unclear.
According to the campaign website, the
film is currently in post-production,
with no hard release date set. Joining
Frank in the cast is Jason Faunt from
"Power Rangers Time Force" and Ciara
Hanna "Power Rangers Megaforce."
According to the movie's website, the plot
follows a humbled warrior returning home
after being defeated in battle. Frank plays Erik
Reed, known as the "White Dragon" before his power
source was destroyed during combat. Without access
to the full breadth of his powers and shunned by
the people he wasn't strong enough to protect,
Reed is determined to defeat the evil wreaking
havoc on his home. However, he'll need more than
luck to regain his powers and avenge his name.
While the premise of the PG-13 film has a
somewhat darker tone than Frank's past work,
Erik Reed's backstory is reminiscent
of Tommy Oliver's storyline in "Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers." Viewers will recall
that the Green Ranger found redemption as
the White Ranger after being freed
from Rita Repulsa's mind control.
"Is it really you?"
"In the flesh."
Despite the otherworldly setting, the lesson
at the heart of the story is based in reality.
Similar to how "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers"
used fantastical storylines to help make the
heartwarming morals pack a punch, the minds behind
"Legend of the White Dragon" used the same tactic
when crafting the plot of the film. According
to Frank, feelings like isolation and regret
inspired his character's emotional journey. Even
though Reed is a character with incredible powers,
he has his problems just like everyone
else. Frank told ComicBook.com back in 2021,
Frank was promoting "Legend of the White
Dragon" in the months leading up to his death,
including showing off the character's helmet and a
fan tattoo on his Instagram. It's unclear when the
film will come out, though Vulture reports it is
currently "expected to release sometime in 2023."